hey brian you're back from vacation huh
so i heard a lot about these squidward
games and i have to write something
about it can you fill me in can i
so you've got this guy gee hoon he's
kind of your average everyday dirtbag
who gives his daughter a gun for her
10th birthday wait what a gun relax it's
just for lighting cigarettes so he's
deep in debt with the loan sharks but
then one day an angel comes along and
throws him a lifeline sounds uplifted is
you ever played pogs when you were a kid
pogs yeah i played okay so you know the
rules somebody gives you eight dollars
every time that you win and if you lose
they get to slap you in the face
what slap pogs is he good at uh slap
pogs he's not great so naturally after
he gets slapped for several hours and
finally wins eight dollars he does what
any of us would do he gives himself over
to a mysterious organization allows
himself to be kidnapped and drugged and
says yes to literally everything it's
sort of like that week i spent at the
improv olympics yes and so anyway
there's a lot of colorful characters
playing these squid games like who for
example well you've got gee hoon of
course you've got dee hoon's mean smart
friend with the glasses you've got old
snake face who's got the snakiest face
of a lot of them you got crazy toilet
lady and her maybe imaginary kids you
got stabby who will stab her way out of
anything if you give her a sharp object
or even a blunt one and of course
you've got a harmless old man who isn't
hiding anything
i like the sound of that last guy so
what sorts of games do they play well do
you remember playing red light green
light as a kid
yes but not with any slapping ryan
don't worry
red light green light is a slap-free
zone
okay cool instead when the big robot
lady turns her head around and she says
red light and you so much as moving
eyebrow the wrong way a sniper rifle
blows half your head clean off it's
super fun
what well it's partly to illustrate just
how brutal this whole squid game is and
it's partly to cut down on background
extras in the pilot episode so that the
craft service's budget doesn't spiral
out of control anyway after that
everyone leaves the game because they
realize it's a brutal exercise in
futility oh thank god but right after
that they all figure out that they live
horrible garbage lives so they just
joined the game again and it takes 45
entire minutes of on-screen misery for
everyone to get to that point oh
cool so we've already established that
you're familiar with red light green
line right not that version but well
they play a lot of other classic
childhood games too this squid game has
everything tug of war carve sugar good
or you'll die murder marbles exploding
glass bridge do all the stabbing before
anyone else can monopoly be serious man
they're not total monsters so the
players fall one by one snake face crazy
toilet lady a harmless old man who isn't
hiding anything
stabby stabby dies oh no not stabby how
does she die it's kind of a great twist
she gets stabbed sure she who lives by
the stab must also die by the stab i
guess this is so bad uh-huh this is the
absolute worst
yeah
can you believe how awful this is not
really who would ever want to actually
watch this let alone pay money for it
wait i thought you liked this oh i loved
it those are just the names of episodes
four through seven
wakka wakka so that takes us to our
titular squid game there are two players
left gi hoon and his mean friend with
glasses only and here's another great
twist he ain't got his glasses no more
what happened to his glasses who gives
you [ __ ] brian i'm trying to tell you
about the squid gang okay so what is the
squid game well it's this game where
they run around for some reason
sometimes on one foot sometimes on two
foots on a court that's shaped like a
squid shaped like a squid yeah you know
a triangle a circle oh let's not forget
a square
i don't a squid you know like when you
were a kid you used to live in a squid
with your parents until they kicked you
out for what kept happening in the
bathroom so now you and three other
dudes share a studio angel fish uh i'm
hanging up i'll give you eight bucks to
keep listening
go on so gee hoon wins his buddy dies
and the squidward set him free and pay
him the billions he's earned by not
dying what about that old man uh which
one the innocent old man who's not
hiding anything oh it turns out that
those were his squid games oh sure so
wait they pay gihon the money
why don't they just kill him i don't
know why don't they just dump him on the
street and then not pay him i don't know
it's just that it seems like this whole
thing is an unnecessarily long build up
to a shaky conclusion that doesn't hold
up to even a single second of narrative
screws he wears a funny red wig at the
end i'm just really confused about all
listen friend it's not the plot that
matters so much as the message the
message is that if you gamble and lose
and gamble and lose and gamble and lose
and gamble and lose and then you gamble
and then you lose and then your wife
leaves you because you gamble and you
lose so much and then you gamble and
then you lose and then you gamble and
you lose again and then someone says
would you like to gamble
there's a pretty good chance you're
gonna be okay
maybe or you'll die it's one of those
[Music]
brian
brian
rybry
guess i get to keep my eight bucks